K I have a question did you do a lot of
improv when you when you were studying
uh acting or preparing or did you just
is this just you never you are such you
know from the first time we met and
started talking and hanging out and this
is why you're always so much fun you're
one of the best yes Anders you are just
you just no but you really are you like
you're very fun and and so I always
thought oh Kaye must have started out
doing improv like so many people I talk
to that is so nice no I'm not like a com
I not comedian I didn't comedian I
didn't take that path I never did improv
I took one acting class when I was 10
years old did I already tell this story
I feel like I probably did okay I think
so I don't think so and you know what we
are I've told so many stories so many
times over about my career in porno so
yeah everyone knows the story we do we
know that story very well no I took one
acting class when I was 10 years old and
I had it was like a um there was a bunch
of kids my age and I had to do a scene
and the acting teacher said to me in
front of all my peers you will not make
it she said you you act you are a pots
and pans actor is what we call someone
like you I was 10 and what she meant by
that was I was you know all over the
place uh messy um not sophisticated that
was what she said to me and I went home
and it balded my eyes out on I mean I
could cry I cry now it really PTS
and my mom I said I'm not going back to
that class and she goes yeah you're
going to finish the class I was like
please don't make me go back I don't
want to go back she thinks I'm so bad I
suck I suck my mom made me go back I
ended up finishing the class it was like
a few months whatever I had to do I
never took another class again but that
woman yeah literally said that to me and
from that point on I've never forgotten
that because I actually do think I am
that kind of actor in a way but in a way
I think that was like a good thing yeah
but she was not thinking that was a good
thing you know we had a couple people
like Harrison Ford has come on here and
and had a similar experience with Jerry
takov and who else came do you want to
name this woman Trac Ellis
Ross you remember her name I just do you
know what's funny we talk about these
things because I always uh sort of a uh
a secret mission of mine in this podcast
mostly it's just to have fun but if I
have a theme that I like to pursue
it's a little inspirational for people
listening which is um it's good for
people to hear from you that you were
told no and we've had so many people
come in here who've had these incredible
careers and they they they share these
stories and I think it's good for people
to know that it's good for people also
to know that some of that insecurity and
some of that doesn't go away later on
just because you've had a lot of success
it's still there that actually like
drives me now because I laugh I'm like I
am kind of like that like I have cre my
own way and that's that's completely
fine but I definitely was told that I
was terrible a long long time ago and
that I would never make it a lot of
things I love about winter time mhm so
cold outside you gather inside with your
Chums yeah your Bros high-five them yeah
and you sit around a crackling fire and
you know what you do what crack open a
cold one that's it isn't it that's it it
is it is it is y and when you crack open
a cold one you better make sure it's
Miller Light ah the best one sit around
there's roaring fire maybe we've just
roasted some chestnuts probably not no
one does that really no then they crack
open a Miller Light and it makes the
conversation kind of flow everyone's
happy you guys are talking about sports
we are talking about sports we're
talking about hockey we're talking about
highly we're talking about trucks we're
talking about cars we're talking about
things we enjoy and every now and then
we stop we high five and we have some
more Miller Light yeah and then it's got
that clean finish oh don't even get me
started on the clean finish and it's
only 96 calories 3.2 carbage per 12
ounces again I did those calculations
millerite Great Taste 96 calories go to
millerlite.com to find out delivery
options near you you don't have to go to
the store delivery options or you can
pick up some mirror light pretty much
anywhere they sell beer if you walk in
and they sell beer my guess is they've
got Miller Light celebrate responsibly
Miller Brewing Company Milwaukee
Wisconson 96 calories and 3.2 carbage
per 12 ounces you know it's interesting
cuz you have this you know crazy Success
With Big Bang
Theory and
I've heard you say that when that was
over you thought well I guess that's it
you know people will see me on the
street for the rest of my life and say
oh hi Penny how you
doing and your career since then has
been you shape-shifting in all these
cool ways yeah um
and you know whether it's like the
flight attendant or like in roleplay you
do these things where you get to do
light comedy but also you get to be
very serious or wounded or um put
through the ringer and you do that
beautifully and so now I feel like
you've carved out this space where no
one could say thank you you're that's
okay we'll let you know Miss sitcom when
we need you but you know what I mean s
thank you thank you I mean I laugh if I
was known as penny for the rest of my
life I'm more than fine with that it was
like the one of the best experiences it
got me to where I am literally right now
um it was amazing and I learned so much
on that show and how to blast yeah I
didn't I kind of thought that too I'm
like well maybe I'll do sitcoms forever
and by the way I love I I love doing
sitcoms I love the schedule I love an
audience so I wasn't I had nothing
against it and then when I found flight
attendant I'm like oh maybe maybe I
could do this like people might I don't
know if they're going to believe I can
do it but I think I can do it and then
kind of created I wanted to do that
drama but also bring in I always have to
add a little you know a little comedy in
there and we kind of turned it into that
and kind of formed our own little tone
and that's what I've what I've run with
but I I think we live in this uh
actually this kind of golden era in
entertainment in my opinion uh and I can
say that as someone who's really not in
it now I mean doing this but but but I I
think there's this really nice era
wherein
where um people try to classify things
and they don't need to be classified so
was that big controversy about the bear
how can the bear be uh you know up for
an Emmy if it's um you know it's they're
saying it's a comedy but it's not a
comedy and people were getting all
worked up about it and I said I don't
really care I really like the bear and
um I don't think there needs to be these
strict classifications anymore and now
there's all this entertainment where I
feel like there these very funny moments
and then very dark moments and then a
character you really like can die so
it's way past Gilligan's Island where
everything everything resets every week
and has to go back to0 zero no exactly
exactly I mean we had that with flight
attendant too I had a lot of people who
were like it's not we were we went up
for comedy and all this St and they were
like you're not a comedy I'm like but it
is kind of a comedy like you're not pimp
P pigeon hold anymore it's all the
things right and it's and everyone has a
different opinion there's so much out
there that's the thing there's so much
out there and all the tones now are all
over the place which makes it I think so
much fun yeah I I was saying the same
thing watching the movie that you just
did where I thought there are really fun
funny moments but then there are also
moments where I don't know is someone
getting killed right now and I love that
the that's the era that I think a whole
generation has come up with yeah which
is we
don't and and there's so many amazing
shows like Breaking Bad that were could
be hilariously funny and comical Brian
Cranston in his tidy
Whitey you know yelling uh while his
meth lab blows up um so many great
comedy moments and then some of like the
the deepest posos that I've
seen that's everywhere now and I know I
know it's so crazy I I can't believe how
long I've been doing this I mean truly I
I you're 77 years old I'm 77 and I want
to thank you for your service in the
Korean War months old I think you you
were there you were at the DMZ long
before they had a gift shop and God
bless you for it been around I have been
around the work you did to get Dwight
Eisenhower elected puts you in rare
company really rare company no it's like
good I I've been doing this so long at
this point now I just want to work with
people I love to work with I want to
have fun I want to do jobs that are fun
I mean dude when I got to heard I got to
come back on call me dude okay that's it
listen I'm 3,000 months old okay I'm
trying to get back with the young
kids